pro ist hannover die juden sind heute
die erste kerze an
sie feiern ihr lichterfest der
achtarmige leuchter der einträchtig
neben dem weihnachtsbaum vor dem
brandenburger tor in berlin steht der
wird allerdings von einem großen
polizeiaufgebot geschützt
nachdem am wochenende dort israelische
fahnen verbrannt wurden
antisemitismus mitten in berlin weltweit
protestieren muslime seit präsident
trump angekündigt hat die us-botschaft
nach jerusalem zu verlegen
amerikas entscheidung hat folgen weit
über das heilige land hinaus islamische
welt in aufruhr wem gehört jerusalem
darüber sprechen wir in dieser phoenix
runde dazu muss sie ganz herzlich und da
sind meine gäste heute abend michael
lüders ist bei uns publizist
nahost-experte und präsident der deutsch
arabischen gesellschaft
ich bin großer eldad beck deutschland
korrespondent der zeitung israel hajom
er lebt seit 2002 in deutschland und
louis muten er hat palästinensische
wurzeln ist nahost experte der deutschen
welle dort verantwortlich für das
internetmagazin contra de das ist dialog
mit der islamischen welt und herzlich
willkommen brigitte fehrle kolumnistin
der berliner zeitung
frau ferne ich habe es eben angesprochen
hier vor dem brandenburger tor steht
dieser ganz große run uka leuchte heute
abend wurde hier die erste kerze
entzündet großes polizeiaufgebot
da hat sich was verändert da stehen eben
das wird abgesperrt am wochenende diese
proteste wie empfinden sie das als
berlinerin
ja es ist natürlich wenn man in dieser
stadt sehr sehr lange lebt und das tue
ich eine sehr bedrückende erfahrung dass
eine ein solches religiöses fest nicht
ohne polizeischutz stattfinden kann aber
es ist eben realität es hat diese
schlimmen proteste gegeben gestern heute
scheint es etwas ruhiger verlaufen zu
sein
und dann bleibt einfach nichts anderes
übrig als zu sagen man muss das schützen
so gut man es schützen kann und man muss
es eben sehr gut schützen
und ich hoffe dass ich das wieder etwas
beruhigt das ist im moment sehr sehr
aufgewühlte situation aber ich glaube es
gibt zwei dinge die man auseinander
muss die proteste die es jetzt gegen
kramp entscheidung gibt und das was es
an antisemitismus in deutschland
inzwischen gibt es muss nicht nur
zwingend übereinstimmen aber es stimmt
eben oft über ein aber würden sie sagen
nach ihrer beobachtung ist gibt einen
wachsenden antisemitismus leer wird der
offen zutage tritt jetzt hier in berlin
also das muss man ganz eindeutig
feststellen die straftaten steigen die
antisemitischen und auch die vorfälle
die so öffentlich bekannt werden
ich erinnere an die geschichte des
jüdischen jungen in einer berliner
schule der gemobbt wurde weil er jude
war bisher die schule verlassen hat das
ist ein extremfall aber den darf es
eigentlich in deutschland und überhaupt
nirgendwo auf der welt geben und wir
sehen es in vielen ländern also auch in
vielen europäischen ländern auch in
frankreich gibt es eine ganz stark
wachsenden antisemitismus unter den
jungen ein waren daran oft ist es die
zweite oder dritte generation die sich
so radikalisiert und da haben wir
überhaupt noch keine wirkliche erklärung
dafür und auch keine wirkliche antwort
drauf
herr beck wie sehen sie es würden sie
sagen das eine hat mit dem anderen jetzt
nicht unbedingt was zu tun oder sind die
proteste die wir jetzt hier sehen hat
das doch etwas klar mit der entscheidung
von charme nicht tun dass er sagt ich
glaube nicht dass wir haben solche
demonstrationen schon öfter in
deutschland und in europa gesehen jedes
mal wenn irgendetwas im land außen
passiert ist es schon eine tradition
geworden dass die gewalt und die terror
die wir dort ständig erleben kommt auch
noch europa und von daher glaube ich
nicht dass es direkt mit der
entscheidung von pump zu tun hat sondern
mit ein bestimmter gewohnheit
jedes mal wenn es ein sozusagen wenn man
nicht der chor ist mit was in der welt
passiert kommen wir zu solcher
gewaltausbrüche und leider ist es so
also ich habe es sie haben jetzt gesagt
ich bin hier in deutschland seit 2002
damals war es die zweite intifada dann
haben wir lieben und kriege gaza krieg
und so weiter und so fort
jedes mal wieder holt es sich dieses
szenario und dann irgendwann kommt eine
reaktion der deutschen behörden die
schöne sachen sagen aber in der tat
nichts tun um das zu verhindern
und von daher haben wir jedes mal genau
eine wiederholung der selbe geschichte
was würden sie sich denn wünsche an den
deutschen behörden also mehr
effektivität in der bekämpfung dieser
kriminalitätsform es geht um gremien
hatten ganz deutlich es geht nicht um
was ganz anderes hat mit politik nichts
zu tun sondern mit menschen die diese
gewohnheit auf sich genommen haben jedes
mal wenn ihnen irgendetwas nicht gefällt
die gehen auf die straßen und machen
gewalt urteilen sie dass die prozesse
die es jetzt gibt und den machen sie
dafür verantworten
na ja wir haben ja wir wissen gar nicht
wer diese proteste also ich weiß nicht
wer das angemeldet hat frische kräfte
dahinter sind wir sind jetzt
wahrscheinlich 250 personen die in der
stadt verantwortlich für die
ausschreitungen
ich finde wir leben die jungen muslime
sind viele junge muslime viele war aber
stimmige muslime das ist richtig ich
finde man wir leben in einer demokratie
in der man auch seine meinung äußern
kann friedlich respektieren ich finde
auch kritik muss konkret sein das heißt
wenn ich mich hinter gegen die oder
protestiere gegen die entscheidung der
amerikanischen präsidenten der muss als
konkret bin ich nicht den
siedlungspolitik und natalia ablehnen da
muss das konkret bin nämlich darf sich
nicht einigen ein kollektiv wenden das
ist ein problem weil die muslime
verraten oder die arabisch stimme den
demonstranten verraten ihre sache wenn
sie ist kollektiv hier eine religiöse
gemeinschaft also die juden oder dafür
verantwortlich machen das ist etwas was
aussieht zurück fehlt denn sie kämpfen
auch für ihre grundrechte in deutschland
die sie kämpfen für mehr sichtbarkeit
der muslime ziemlich auch für die dafür
für das recht der frauen kopflose tragen
eine wohlig ein säkularer milch das
etikett muss konkret sein muss ganz klar
punktuell muss akteure sind riet sein
aber wir wissen ja gar nicht wer
dahinter steckt ob das die hisbollah das
historie sicherheit haben wir es ja
natürlich mit einer gewissen kräften
sind natürlich diese diese diesen rausch
der empörung für ihre zwecke
denn für dienstliche zwecke
instrumentalisieren
das muss man auch klar benennen und das
führt natürlich zu der debatte das haben
sie in der anmoderation ja erwählen die
islamische welt ein aufruf
ich bezweifle es gibt nicht die
islamische welt es gibt ja auch nicht
islam ist kein akteur es gibt einzelne
staaten mit einem interesse und
politische gruppierungen die natürlich
bestimmte ereignisse für ihre zwecke
das iranische regime ich habe hisbollah
genannt ich mich würde interessieren da
wurde ich werde die dahinter steckt
jedenfalls ist ist sie schadet damit der
eigenen sachen so das ist
verabscheuungswürdig und das gehört
nichts heute warte zum diskurs in diesem
land wir haben jedes jahr in berlin
jerusalem tag diese demonstration die
immer wieder voll mit hass und gewalt
sind von daher alles was wir heute sehen
ist nichts neues das passiert jedes jahr
und die bundesregierung tut überhaupt
nichts und dazu verbinden diese meiner
kunden das ist ein klassisches beispiel
von astro mental easy hrung des
palästina konflikt und das iranische
regime das in den letzten jahren kamen
immer weniger menschen zu diesem soll
diese veranstaltung aufgrund der stetig
so mädchen spannungen und der haltung
iran in syrien zudem die mehrheit der
sonne hin hat sich davon abgewandt ist
klar ich bin lieder für dafür genau
hinzuschauen wer dahintersteckt und
assist hilft uns nicht weiter zu sagen
allem auch bühne ja auch wie man merken
wir dass dieser konflikt dass der
nahostkonflikt eben hier bei uns im land
sozusagen auch eine rolle spielt und
auch instrumentalisiert wird hätte das
versuchen wir sortieren was bedeutet
diese entscheidung von trump weil
dadurch ist es jetzt alles wieder
hochgekommen
was heißt das und was bedeutet eben
jerusalem für die verschiedenen gruppen
und warum ist er so eine zentrale
entscheidung gewesen
ja das ist ein viele aspekte die man
hier ansprechen muss vielleicht ist es
erstmal sinnvoll daran zu erinnern was
ist eigentlich der status von jerusalem
wir haben den letzten tagen und wochen
immer wieder in den medien auch von
politikern gehört dass jerusalem
umstritten sei die palästinensische
seite würde auch jerusalem für sich
beanspruchen
und das bleibt so ein bisschen im nebel
was ist eigentlich die rechtliche lage
ich glaube wir können jetzt stundenlang
untereinander diskutieren und werden zu
ganz unterschiedlichen auffassungen
kommen wir jetzt möglicherweise was
gehört wenn wir aber das völkerrecht zum
maßstab nehmen muss man ganz klar sagen
dass mit der israelischen besatzung von
ost jerusalem 1967
der ostteil der stadt von israel
annektiert worden ist formell vollzogen
wurde dieser schritt im jahre 1980
dieser schritt ist eindeutig
völkerrechtswidrig dagegen darüber gibt
es gar nicht zu diskutieren dazu
verhandeln die folge rechtliche normen
ist hier eindeutig ost jerusalem gehört
nach maßgabe des völkerrechtes nicht zum
israelisches gebiet sondern
es ist ein gebiet das idealerweise nach
friedensverhandlungen im kontext eines
friedensprozesses die hauptstadt werden
könnte oder sollte eines
palästinensischen staates ursprünglich
war die idee der vereinten nationen als
israel gegründet wurde das jerusalem und
der internationale auszeichnungen werden
uns das ja sollte neutral sein aus genau
diesem grund hat auch nie ein land auch
vor 1967 nicht die eigene botschaft nach
jerusalem verlegt sondern diese
botschaften gibt es in tel aviv stehen
und diese entscheidung von präsident
trump hat nun dazu geführt dass
natürlich in der arabischen welt nicht
in islamischen welt unter den
palästinensern
das gefühl entstanden ist dieser
friedensprozesse seit jahren geführt
wird und die haben grünen haben eine
phase ist er nirgendwohin führt der sold
von frieden geredet es wird die fiktion
aufrechterhalten einer zwei staaten
lösung eines palästinensischen staates
an der seite israels entstehen soll
aber wir sehen dass durch die
israelische siedlungspolitik überhaupt
kein raum mehr da ist für einen
palästinensischen staat muss immer klar
bleiben wir mal bei jerusalem ist gleich
mit wenn man in jerusalem ist merkt man
es eben auch besonders man steht an der
klagemauer man schaut mit dem tempelberg
wo die moschee ist die al-aksa-moschee
und der felsendom also ein merck das ist
ein ganz also ein zentraler platz der
für alle religionen so wichtig ist und
für die christen in jerusalem auch
wichtig was bedeutet ihnen jerusalem
jerusalem ist die heiligste stadt das
judentum die einzige heilige stadt
das würde uns und ich muss sagen da bin
ich ein bisschen erstaunt dass man über
völkerrecht spricht in bezug auf status
von jerusalem weil so eindeutig ist es
überhaupt nicht
ich meine der der ostteil von jerusalem
wurden wurde 1948 von jordanien besetzt
da man hat man aber über keine besitzen
besatzung gesprochen
interessanterweise obwohl die von
jordanien ein muslimisches land ist ist
der ostteil von jerusalem die hauptstadt
von jordanien geworden sondern ammann
ist die hauptstadt geblieben
1948 wird der west teil von jerusalem
aber die hauptstadt von israel das ist
eine tatsache
und jetzt kommen wir zu einer andere
korrektur es gab kein schafften in
jerusalem von bestimmten
südamerikanischen staaten und die haben
ihre entscheidung die botschaft dort zu
haben geändert weil es druck aus der
arabischen staaten kam noch ein punkt
der sehr wichtig ist die europäische
union die anscheinend überhaupt keine
positionen jetzt haben will
über den status von jerusalem hat eine
vertretung in jerusalem will aber nicht
dass jerusalem
aber es ist irgend etwas das die eu
vertretung in ost jerusalem ist und
nicht im west jerusalem
da nimmt man eigentlich die
palästinensische position die behauptet
jerusalem ist die hauptstadt von
palästina und nicht von israel also also
meine wenn wir über objektivität
speichern wieder schön
also wir haben ja wir haben ja wie
kommen die es gegen die analyse erst
richtig der amerikanische kongress hat
1996 einen beschluss gefasst der nachdem
die die administration einem café
us-administration verpflichtet werden
die haben die amerikanische botschaft
nach jerusalem zu verlegen alle
amerikanischen präsidentin bis dadurch
haben aus einer klausel gebrauch gemacht
um diese entscheidung pro jede sechs
monaten zu verziehen
es herrschte so etwas ich nehme das
international konsens darüber dass man
den endgültigen status jerusalems für
eine verhandlungslösung quasi offen
links das ist ja trump hat aus
innenpolitischen gründen eine böse zunge
mann aus familiären gründen hat diesen
konsens gebrochen ist nicht mehr da
und das führt zu der frage welche lösung
überhaupt überhaupt realistischen der
region also wir haben
man hat ja die diese konsens verteidigt
auch durch die europäer weil man
ganz genau aber irgendwie idealer war
sie brauchen wir eine international
favorisierte zweistaatenlösung mit west
jerusalem als hauptstadt israels und
idealerweise ost jerusalem als
hauptstadt eines war das wenig staat
das ist quasi die internationale konsens
die ist nicht mehr gibt im augenblick
was denken sie frau wusste war prompt
die die reichweite seiner entscheidung
klar
also die frage vermag ich wirklich nicht
zu beantworten weil ich in den kopf und
formt nicht reinschauen kann wenn man
die das ergebnis sich aber an schaut
also wenn man es von von jetzt an
analysiert kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
dass ihm das wirklich klar gewesen ist
er hat eben nicht als außenpolitiker
gehandelt er hat als innenpolitiker
gehandelt er hat in dem letzten jahr
sehr wenig von dem durchsetzen können
was er versprochen hat im wahlkampf und
das war jetzt eben eine sache die er
sehr vielen leuten versprochen hat und
deswegen glaube ich ist er dazu gekommen
dieses zu tun er hat es ja oft nur
halbherzige art und weise gemacht er hat
gesagt ich bekenne mich zu jerusalem als
der hauptstadt hat aber gleichzeitig ja
wieder dieses papier unterschrieben was
die verzögerung mit sich bringt also er
wollte einen fakt schaffen aber ihn dann
tatsächlich nicht nicht wirklich
umsetzen
also das ist eine sehr sehr halbherzige
und und wankelmütige sache gewesen von
von vorn
ich glaube sie ist rein politisch
motiviert und hat damit eine eine
weltpolitische situation geschaffen die
ich wirklich unverantwortlich finde und
mit der wir jetzt alle ganz ganz schwer
zu tun haben werden
aber warum ist denn die aufregung so
groß in der arabischen welt wenn man die
mir jetzt folgt das aus für alle sagt
dass man das ist eigentlich auch eine
innenpolitische entscheidung und es gibt
dann doch diese klausel also trotzdem
ist die aufregung so groß waren
es hat zu tun mit dem gefühl von
demütigung es hat zu tun mit dem gefühl
von ausweglosigkeit
wir haben millionen von palästinensern
die sich sehnen
der einsatz von israelischer besatzung
zu leben und sie erkennt natürlich dass
sie keine chance haben auf ihren eigen
start die zweistaatenlösung die
sozusagen die offizielle formel ist mit
blick auf eine lösung zwischen israelis
und palästinensern ist doch reine
rhetorik jeder weiß dass es diesen
palästinensischen staat niemals geben
wird zum einen weil die israelischen
siedlungsblöcke so viel land gefressen
haben im westjordanland das gar kein
platz mehr ist für die gründung eines
lebensfähigen palästinensischen staates
und zum anderen ist die agenda der
regierung netanjahu die getragen wird
von ultranationalisten von siedlern von
religiösen kräften ihn denkt noch nicht
im traum daran einen palästinensischen
staat zuzulassen weil aus deren
perspektive das gesamte netz israel das
gesamte üblich verheißene land zwischen
mittelmeer und jordan am jordan-fluss
ausschließlich der jüdischen bevölkerung
gehört was diese kreis aber in der regel
nicht öffentlich diskutieren oder wo sie
vielleicht auch keine meinung über haben
ist die frage was auch nicht geschehen
mit den vielen palästinensern vergleich
vergessen wir nicht wir haben heute
zwischen mittelmeer und jordan fluss
leben weniger juden als nichtjuden zum
teil sind sie staatsbürger israels viele
sagen sie sind bürger zweiter klasse
und wie haben die palästinenser unter
israelischer besatzung die bürger sind
dritter vierter fünfter klasse überhaupt
keine rechte haben dass das auf dauer
nicht geht dass eine jüdische minderheit
über einen nicht jüdische mehrheit
herrscht kann eigentlich jeder wissen
und das sagen ja auch heute schon
israelische politiker und intellektuelle
dass das keine perspektive hat die
entscheidung jerusalem jetzt
anzuerkennen als hauptstadt israels ist
eine rein innenpolitische in der tat
es hat zu tun damit dass er im wort
steht gegenüber mächtigen spender
gegenüber einer sehr wirkungsmächtigen
pro israelischen lobby und natürlich
gegenüber den christlich klerikalen
kräften den fundamentalisten die mit
dieser entscheidung natürlich sehr sehr
glücklich sind ja was hatte ich noch
einige sachen uhr nur ergänzen das
tragische daran ist ja eigentlich auch
dass kramp er angekündigt hat er möchte
eine neue nahost friedensinitiative
staaten einen big deal oder wie es
genannt hat er hat aber kein plan
vorgelegt und hat eine einzelne
entscheidung getroffen die im grunde
genommen die ganze atmosphäre und die
stimmung jetzt auf eine weise produziert
dass man sich gar nicht mehr vorstellen
kann wie dieser plan aussieht jedenfalls
nicht als ein diplomatischer plan der
alle akteure
sozusagen gemeinsam versucht an einen
tisch zu bringen und wirklich einen
frieden mich im sinne von einem sieg der
ein über die andere seite sondern von
einem frieden der auch dann am ende eine
tragfähigkeit hat gehört dass man erst
mal reden wir über den aufruf
ich sehe diesen auf nicht wirklich wir
hätten sehr gern darüber wir machen uns
angst es gibt hier um dort ein paar
demonstrationen die ziemlich üblich ist
aber so eine große welle von gewalt
er sagt also ich glaube dass nach der
geschichte der mohammed karikaturen
hatten wir schon ziemlich viel mehr
gewalt auf den straßen deshalb mit
mehreren sachen zu tun also erstmal
glaube ich dass die menschen im nahen
osten andere probleme zurzeit haben also
was in japan passiert diese humanitäre
katastrophe was in syrien passiert was
in libyen passiert umso weiter sofort
die liste jetzt ziemlich gut hat mit
jerusalem nichts zu tun und die menschen
sehen eigentlich endlich mal dass im
nahen osten nicht nur ein konflikt gibt
sondern mehrere konflikte und es hat
nicht wirklich mit israel zu tun sondern
mit anderen sachen bleiben eher in
arabischen ländern um dort spricht man
tatsächlich von diesem großes die von
diesem großen deal von von vom
präsidenten krank und es gibt eine große
erwartung ich glaube dass wir sollen
nicht die gesamte situation im nahen
osten vom augen verlieren das heißt es
passieren zurzeit sachen zum beispiel
ich habe nicht gesehen dass saudi
arabien die emiraten bahrain ägypten
jordanien so vehement gegen den
beschluss von trump reagiert haben
es gibt irgendetwas im nahen osten zur
zeit und ich warte wie andere menschen
zu sehen inwiefern ist trump fähig
tatsächlich diese animosität die in der
region herrscht gegenüber iran und die
hisbollah und andere organisationen um
was neues im nahen osten zu tun
er hat gesagt was bis jetzt war ist
nicht mehr und ich will was neues
schaffen
das heißt sie sehen darin auch eine
chance absolut absolut ich sehe darin
auch eine chance aber von einer anderen
seite ist wahr dass wir wieder um es mit
denen er sich den realität in den
mittleren osten befassen also wir haben
ja konstatiert gerade hallo das ist das
sehr schön formuliert wir verstehen ja
die international favorisierte vor mit
einer zwei staaten lösung ist quasi
obwohl es ist einfach systematisch
verbraucht wird der weg also die eu auch
die internationale gemeinschaft hat
zugelassen dass sie faktisch nicht mehr
aber sie sagt immer noch dass sie daran
die jahre das jedoch nicht alltäglich
theoretisch ist das möglich aber
faktisch also mit dem ball was die
palästinenser bekommen dass es band just
a herab das ist ein moderator respekt
vor mir respektierten politiker aber
seine eigene volk nimmt ihn auch nicht
mehr ernst und viele anderen hat viele
gründe auch natürlich der niederung oder
die missachtung durch die zeitlichen
regierungen also mahmud abbas oder sagen
auch fast alle ist realistin es wird
keinen besseren partner als mahmud abbas
bekommen weil die eu außenbeauftragte
ungarinnen sagt ganz klar die zwei
staaten lösung ist die einzige
realistische lösung des konfliktes
da sind wir gerade im kern des der
problematik also wenn diese einzige
realistische lösung sich nicht um 17
realisiert liest was dann stehen wir am
ende der ideen
da mussten wir über andere intelligente
konföderation löse andere formen denke
und da ich gehen wir natürlich vor allem
dilemma was den palast in dieser basiert
sie haben einen recht in ihrem
heimatland leben in würde und freiheit
auch ohne besatzung das ist ja nicht es
gibt hier in der debatte teilweise
abenteuerliche fantasielosen gegen die
israelische besatzung zur besatzung von
hammers damals ist kein problem aber das
kann heute so das ist aber verbindlich
an die palästinenser das muss man sagen
haben was ist eine von nicht auch eine
bornierte organisation eine ideologisch
pro meter wurde ein gewinn von sagt hat
und die er den allerdings auch genau so
viel schaden zugefügt hatte aber es
funktioniert trotzdem noch mächtig sind
gerade im gange aber die ist so isoliert
wie
so isoliert wie im augenblick aber ich
wurde zu einem anderen punkt nämlich
diese punkte die realität in mittlerer
osten sie haben vollkommen recht mit
einer sache das thema das die das dass
wir in einer auflösung der arabischen
welt erleben dass arabische staaten
andere sorgen haben und dass die
verlasst die nachfrage nicht mehr im
mittelpunkt steht ich würde sogar so
weit gehen und sagen dass die arabischen
zentralen staaten wie saudi arabien die
wahl hast du wirklich gesagt ich schon
aufgegeben haben und trompete diese
entscheidung nie getroffen ohne grünes
licht von riad in saudi arabien von den
arabischen emirate es gab sogar ein
heftiges treffen sich in muhammad bin
salman der de facto allein machthabern
saudi arabien mahmud abbas und mohammad
informant hat den abbau seien ein
angebot gemacht und hat ihm gesagt er
soll die sind big deal akzeptieren
also das heißt wir erleben gibt sich
vieles
da sollen wir schauen was ist noch real
den blick was zu retten aber jetzt
versucht ja erdogan die islamische welt
da zusammenzuführen und es wird morgen
ein treffen geben
diese liga werde das wie sehen sie denn
welche gibt es da ein neues machtzentrum
dass erdogan da versucht seine macht zu
vergrößern seinen einfluss in dem
bereich daran das war ein politischer
opportunismus versucht vorteile für sich
und seine regierung heraus zuschlagen wo
er es kann
und hat sich ja sehr drastisch
rhetorisch positioniert gegenüber israel
nach dieser entscheidung aber
gleichzeitig sind die handelsbeziehungen
zwischen der türkei und israel sehr
intensiv also es wird hier sehr sehr
viel natürlich geredet aber all diese
überlegungen die wir haben auch mit
blick auf die arabische verhält es geht
immer wieder zurück auf die kernfrage
was geschieht mit den palästinensern
trump hat trump hat natürlich durchaus
einen plan für den nahen osten er hat
signalisiert na ja im prinzip müssen die
israelis und palästinenser sich selber
untereinander einig werden darüber wie
sie dieses problem lösen und das ist
natürlich nicht gesagt aber so
funktioniert politik nicht man kann
nicht einer jahr kolonial agierenden
besatzungsmacht israel ein land das
völkerrechtswidrig seit 1967 die
palästinensischen gebiete besetzt hält
und den palästinensern hat das leben zur
hölle macht die entscheidung darüber
entlassen
überlassen was ist mit den
palästinensern macht wenn wir uns einmal
vor augen führen also sogenannte
vermitteln es müsste idealerweise etwas
vermitteln die usa tun das nicht haben
sich verabschiedet sie sind kein
ehrlicher makler sie waren es im grunde
genommen nie wirklich aber jetzt durch
die person von donald trumps endgültig
klar geworden das ist nicht eine reale
vermittlungs handlung von den usa
ausgeht eigentlich wäre jetzt die stunde
der europäischen union wenn wir in der
besten aller eltern leben würden nur die
jetzt die europäische union in führung
gehen das tut sie aber natürlich nicht
es gibt innerhalb der europäischen union
unterschiedliche auffassungen zum thema
israel palästina ist es interessant
daran zu erinnern dass 136
mitgliedsstaaten der vereinten nationen
den staat palästina anerkannt haben aber
nur acht staaten europäischen union und
natürlich auch deutschland hat das
bisher nicht gemacht den staat palästina
anzuerkennen
die deutschen sind der meinung die
deutsche politik ist natürlich in einer
schwierigen situation aber sie versäumt
ist klare forderungen zu stellen an die
israelische seite stehen drücken wird
daran aber wenn ich diesen punkt dann
kurz erwähnen darf man vergibt so viele
möglichkeiten wir haben jetzt zum
dritten mal hat deutschland beschlossen
die bundesregierung bot an israel zu
liefern
darunter mit massiver beteiligung des
hiesigen steuerzahlers der mit einer
halben milliarde euro sich daran
beteiligen wird an diesen kosten
warum wieso weshalb der deutsche
steuerzahler jetzt robot exporte
subventioniert er schließlich mehr
rational nicht rein theoretisch könnte
man noch sagen an die adresse der
israelischen regierung gerichtet wenn
ihr mit uns auf dieser ebene kooperieren
wollten erwarten wir von euch eine
gegenleistung zb ein einfrieren der
siedlungspolitik
man stellt diese forderung gar nicht
erst und das ist etwas was ich aber dann
wären wir ja eine aktive position fährt
auch denken wie wer wird könnte
vermitteln wie würden sie es gegeben die
die eu die sich eben nicht einig ist wie
sehen sie die rolle deutschlands da drin
also im moment ist das ganz ganz
schwierig weil das dass das nahost
quartett ist sozusagen nicht mehr
existent also amerika hat sich daraus
verabschiedet und die die eu ist all das
hat es eben schon erwähnt ist in der
frage des dieses konfliktes des
palästinensischen konfliktes ist die eu
nicht spricht dann nicht mit einer
stimme
und zwar zunehmend weniger mit einer
wie man jetzt gesehen hat bei dem
treffen als netanyahu nach brüssel
gefahren ist und sozusagen quer
eingeladen wurde gar nicht von der eu
direkt und auf war sie eigene eigene
initiative hin gefahren ist es das kann
man auch kritisieren dass es diese
kontakte überhaupt gar nicht gibt ich
finde das auch bedenklich also dass die
eu mit merten mit netanya oder mit den
israelis über offensichtlich seit 22
jahren nicht gesprochen hat es
vollkommen unverständlich aber ob europa
im moment in der lage ist eine
vermittlerrolle einzunehmen dass das
kann ich mir im augenblick gar nicht
vorstellen also außer der un ist
eigentlich überhaupt keine glaubwürdige
institution mehr da die da etwas bewegen
kann und das was trump jetzt eingebracht
hat ist ja sozusagen das recht des
stärkeren dort dann dort sich
durchsetzen zu lassen und das kann keine
wirkliche lösung sagen herr beck sagt er
könnte auch eine chance sein wenn man
jetzt und könnte und das sage hat auch
die es ist eine chance wenn ich das sei
eine chance das überhaupt eine bewegung
wieder entsteht aber das ist jetzt
erstmal ganz neutral gesagt also wohin
diese bewegung dann geht ob die zu einer
was ich vorhin gesagt habe zu einer
befriedung führt die dann wirklich einen
frieden bringt oder ob sie nur eine
bestimmte machtoption dann am ende
zementiert das ist ja damit überhaupt
gar nicht gesagt also die un
botschafterin der usa nikki haley hat
gesagt es ist ein schritt in richtung
frieden weil trump die jerusalem-frage
vom tisch genommen hat aber das ist das
was ich sage das ist sozusagen das recht
des stärkeren durchgesetzt er hat sich
auf eine seite gestellt hat gesagt ich
unterstütze in dieser frage israel und
die palästinensischen interessen sind
mir da egal das ist aber das ende der
diplom 100 iger aber er hat nichts
anderes getan als tatsache anzuerkennen
da hat so gar nicht gesagt ganz
jerusalem ist hauptstadt von israel
sondern hat jerusalem gesagt sie haben
vorher mich korrigiert nicht zurecht auf
arabisch heißt jerusalem
von daher hat im amt nicht gesagt ich
anerkenne al quds als hauptstadt von
israel ja also ich meine was er gemacht
ist absolut symbolisch und erst mal dass
zweitens hat er gezeigt dass man
irgendeine bewegung doch schaffen kann
wenn man den israelis das gibt was
eigentlich sie schon seit fast 60 jahren
haben eine haaren oder wäre es eine
möglichkeit zu sagen west jerusalem
gehört israel aus jerusalem gehört
palästina einem er hat es mehr oder
weniger gesagt er hat nicht gesagt ich
gebe das ganze an israel hat gesagt was
die was das gebiet von jerusalem sein
sollte wird später entschieden das hat
er gesagt und das hat auch die
botschafterin bei der uno gesagt das ist
sehen sie den ruhen die usa immer noch
in der rolle des vermittlers in diesem
in diesem konflikt sagen sie das ist
eine möglichkeit oder sind sie da raus
weil sich so auf eine seite position
also wir haben vorher von
innenpolitischen gründen gesprochen von
wir haben von jüdisches geld gesprochen
wir haben von familiären gründen
gesprochen wir haben aber vergessen dass
die palästinenser was bei ionesco
gemacht haben
wir haben versucht die geschichtliche
verbindung zwischen juden und jerusalem
offiziell abzulehnen und haben es
geschafft
es passiert oft in unesco dass
entscheidungen die die verbindung
zwischen juden und jerusalem ablehnen
entschlossen werden und das haben die
palästinenser initiiert und durchgeführt
und die entscheidung von über jerusalem
ist eine direkte reaktion auf diese
palästinensische freiheit weil was
liefern heißt es gar nicht wollen halt
noch ein bisschen erklären was es hinauf
wird es gibt einen schluss von unesco
dass man alle sechs monate seit vier
oder fünf jahren entscheidet der
behauptet dass die juden keine beziehung
zu jerusalem haben und dass israel in
jerusalem eine besatzungsmacht ist und
die reaktion von trump war ganz einfach
erst mal hat er unesco verlassen
und zweitens hat gesagt ich erkenne
jerusalem als hauptstadt von israel des
jüdischen staates an alle sind ist
sicher sagen er habe ich vom symbol
ich bin nicht der meinung des kreises
trage ich dass die eu alles ökonomischer
krise eigentlich ein sich politisch
wenig politisch so unter wert
präsentiert und verkauft das ist
wirklich tragisch aber ich will noch
zwei punkte hinweisen
ich glaube nicht dass die eu komplett
machtlos ist man kann auch jetzt
angesichts der gewaltigen symbole diese
ja betont rapid und haben zu recht auch
genauso eine andere symbolik an den
tagen die man kann natürlich eine
stehende eu vertretung in ost-jerusalem
als gäste des ausgleichs reichen
anerkennen also quasi provisorische
botschaft dann alles quasi geste der
anerkennung für einen möglichen verlauf
sie unseren staat in der zukunft das
kann man machen das kann auch
deutschland macht ich sehe die
bereitschaft nicht dazu das wäre
natürlich auch eine bestätigung den
willen das des willens dass man will
dass am ende des endlich in west
jerusalem als hauptstadt israels ost
jerusalem als hauptstadt eines zu
gründenden weil es unser staat ist das
der erste punkt der zweite punkt der
welt politisch wirklich bedeutsam ist
auch für uns auf in europa ist ich
glaube nicht das hat herr lüders nur
angeschnitten dass die usa in der
zukunft größere investitionen große
rolle im mittleren osten spielen werden
also dass die ära das zeitalter der
amerikanischen vorherrschaft im
mittleren osten
eigentlich ist so und neigt sich dem
ende zu schon jetzt
spielend in die atmosphäre vielleicht
schlecht ist insofern alles einfach
kommen die steht entsteht dass die
europäer zum beispiel nicht füllen
können das ist auch weiter chaotische
zustände herrschen wie wir die wir nicht
mehr unter kontrolle haben wir haben die
schon hits wie gesagt ich habe das
angesprochen eine eine krise des
arabischen nationalismus staaten
befinden sich in einer auflösung ägypten
steht vor dem niedergang von einem
syrien kann gar keine rede sein
der irak alle postkoloniale arabischen
staaten befinden sich konnte kurz vor
dem ende das heißt wie er leben starken
dass wir gehört auch durch staat israel
trotz aller stärke die im grunde
genommen nicht die soziale und
gesellschafter realität indem ich in
repräsentieren deren grenzen nicht klar
sind ihre identität in dieser
leistungsfähigkeit und eine
entwicklungsperspektive überhaupt ein
für grundverständnis dafür für diese
epochale umbrüche die hat man in europa
lich entwickelt man merkt man dass an
der em der wirklich bescheiden
reaktionen der europäer auf die araber
nun man wusste gar nicht wie man darauf
reagiert stattliche lissmann sich um für
führen von von einem unfähigen putsch
general hars ist sie von deren natalie
hof von einer korrupten präsentieren
behörden also eine klare linie wie man
damit umgeht nach wenn euch originale
wie gefährlich ist das dann wenn man
solche konkret dann mal schauen bei den
palästinensern es gibt eine umfrage ist
heute von der konrad-adenauer-stiftung
da sagen jetzt 44 prozent der
palästinenser sie sind für den
bewaffneten widerstand zur schaffung
schaffung eines eigenen staates vor drei
monaten waren das noch 35 prozent
45 prozent sprechen sich für eine neue
intifada aus das ist eine umfrage die
nach der entscheidung von von trump die
botschaft zu verlegen gemacht wurde
als er sie das wie gefährlich ist denn
das wie viel druck ist da im kessel und
wie schnell kann das platzen na ja also
ich meine dass die palästinenser die
historischen verlierer sind in die haben
in ihrer auseinandersetzung der
jüdischen besiedlung palästinas vor 1948
und mit dem staat israel 1948 das ist
offenkundig
diese entscheidung jerusalem als
hauptstadt israels anzuerkennen ist im
grunde genommen noch mal eine
zusätzliche einer abschließenden
demütigung wenn man so will die
palästinenser wissen dass sie keine
chance haben wenn sie sich gewalttätig
verhalten dann gelten dass terroristen
mit dem man nicht verhandelt sind sie
gemäßigt und das ist
ja was der leute palästinensischen
autonomiebehörde uneingeschränkt
bekommen sie von israelischen seite
nichts dass bei der unesco die israel in
amerika verlassen haben dass die
palästinenser sehr wohl eine große
chance haben die palästinenser versuchen
ihre internationale anerkennung zu
erreichen und da geben gibt es mächtige
politische interessen in israel den usa
aber die genau dieses zu verhindern
versuchen dass die palästinenser in
internationalen institutionen als staat
palästina anerkannt werden denn das
offizielle argument israels lautet ja
das muss erstmal abschließende
verhandlungen geben verhandlungen die
man seit 50 jahren führt seit 50 jahren
die israelische besatzung des
westjordanlandes und was haben diese
verhandlung gebracht nichts solange die
regierung in israel weiß dass sie
keinerlei druck zu gewärtigen hat und
das hat sie nicht usa werden sollen
nicht unter druck setzen die europäer
werden ist eigentlich unter druck setzen
netanjahu hat ein freibrief zu tun was
immer zu tun beliebt und die israelische
rechte darf man nicht unterschätzen sie
ist er wirkungsmächtig ihre religiösen
und in ihrer ultra nationalistischen
ausrichtung die ganze region
dieselmotoren völlig zu recht gesagt
haben befindet sich in einem umbruch
und wir dürfen jetzt nicht glauben naja
gut jetzt aber nicht so viel protest
gegeben diese gegen jerusalem
entscheidung gegeben also geht das schon
irgendwie gut sondern die regionen die
wahrheit ist es eine umbruchphase wohin
sich die region entwickelt wissen wir
heute nicht wir wissen nicht wie es in
zwei drei oder fünf jahren dort aussieht
klar ist dass all diese konflikte einer
lösung bedürfen niemand hat den
gordischen knoten eine idee wie man ihn
zu schlagen kann
aber wir haben gewisse haben die messe
radar aber wir haben schon gefallen und
wir haben einen hegemon in der region
der sozusagen nach eigenen spielregeln
spielt das geht auf dauer aber nicht
gehalten sind
die israelische regierung wird auf dauer
nicht ihren willen den palästinensern
aufzwingen können und der iran was sie
angesprochen haben ist ein land dessen
politische führung nicht lieben muss
wahrhaftig nicht und gleichzeitig muss
man sich trotzdem mit dem iran ins
benehmen aber selbst dann nicht man muss
auch mit der israelischen regierung
gegenrede jeder redet mit herr netanjahu
aber leider gibt es eben wenig druck auf
ihn ist es in diesem zusammenhang
aber ich meine vision hören ständig die
ganze zeit mehr druck auf israel mehr
und mein blut es tatsächlich von der
seele und warum kann es kein treffen
zwischen israels und europäer gibt und
die bundesregierung erhöht auch den
druck auf israel
es gab eine verzögerung mit der mit der
entscheidung über u boote genau deswegen
was ist also ich meine das hat nichts
gebracht warum man es gab da spricht man
spricht man überhaupt darüber nicht also
die palästinenser sollen weiter mit ihr
gewalttaten machen
das ist ganz normal drück auf denen zu
machen um das zu stoppen das bitteschön
nicht also um es nochmal zu
versachlichen würde ich gerne mal
zurückkehrt aber nicht wirklich grund
ich würde gerne mal auf den grund jeder
kann natürlich unterschiedlich diesen
konflikt beurteilen aber die maßgabe es
zu tun sollte doch idealerweise der
rückgriff seien auf internationaler
rechtsnormen
denn nur diese können wenn man eben
nicht das recht des stärkeren haben will
in der internationalen politik dazu
führen dass man eine regelung
herbeiführen wenn wir es zulassen dass
israel auf dauer die palästinenser
herrscht völkerrechtswidrig dann müssen
wir uns nicht wundern wenn andere länder
auf die liste kommt und versenden von
ihrerseits ihre interessen gewaltsam
durchzusetzen also kurzum wir brauchen
lösungen die komplex sind wir müssen mit
allen reden aber es keiner soll weiter
sehen gehen dass wir eine politik haben
die hegemonie die einigen akteuren alle
freiheiten lässt einander müssen es nur
zur kenntnis nehmen wenn man darauf
nicht reagiert dann haben wir noch mehr
terror noch mehr gewollt noch mal stand
aber wir haben seit 50 jahren kommen wir
da nicht weiter vorfälle welche
positionen müsste deutschland da ein
leben mit der besonderen verantwortung
die deutschland hat also deutschland
müsste zunächst mal innerhalb der eu
dafür sorgen dass die eu mehr einfluss
nimmt und zwar jetzt nicht also auch
druck auf israel aber es wir haben ja
hier zwei akteure in diesem in diesem
konflikt die natürlich nicht
gleichberechtigt sind das sehe ich wie
herr lüders
aber es geht trotzdem nicht ohne dass
diese beiden parteien sich dort auf
irgendeine weise verständigen und
deutschland hätten hat natürlich israel
gegenüber eine ganz besondere
verantwortung das hat die
schülerinnen damals bei ihrem besuch in
israel ja sehr klar gesagt genau
es gehört zur deutschen staatsräson
deswegen hat deutschland eine ganz
besondere verantwortung und müsste
innerhalb der eu die führerschaft
übernehmen das europa da eine
verantwortung übernimmt ich glaube nicht
dass es sinn machen würde wenn
deutschland alleine versucht innerhalb
des nahost konfliktes zu vermitteln weil
natürlich innerhalb der auch der
palästinensischen welt deutschland
natürlich auch gesehen wird als jemand
der sich aus historischen gründen immer
auf die seite israels stellen würde und
deswegen ist es für deutschland alleine
schwierig aber innerhalb der euro
innerhalb europas müsste deutschland
mehr initiative ergreifen dass europa
wieder stärker wird in diesem lag aber
der entscheidende punkt ist am ende wenn
ich das noch sagen darf der
entscheidende punkt ist ja wirklich wenn
es stimmt dass die zwei staaten lösung
gescheitert ist und es sieht ja im
moment so aus dann stellt sich genau die
frage die halle das vorhin gesagt hat
was eigentlich dann und wenn frau
margarine jetzt sagt sie hält an der
zwei-staaten-lösung fest dann ist ja der
einzige grund warum sie das sagt weil
sie nichts anderes heißen und an dem
punkt steht dieser konflikt und sie
haben gesagt das ist eine chance was
trump gemacht hat ich sehe im moment
nicht was ich daraus positiv entwickelt
aber auf jeden fall ist es eine
umbruchsituation oder nehmt mir eine
zuspitzung der situation wo jetzt alle
ihre verantwortung versuchen müssen
wahrzunehmen wie ist es aus
palästinensischer sicht wenn die rolle
deutschland sie wird die da beurteilt
eigentlich sehr positiv man die
deutschland gehört zu den großen vier at
präsentieren behörde durch und sieht
auch sehr viele aufbauprojekte das ist
das ist eigentlich ja ja sebastian weiß
natürlich auch unter dem wir das nicht
in eliten dass deutschland alleine
nichts zustande bringen kann
ohne eine gemeinsame europäische
position aber ich denke aber dass die
europäer sind bei jetzt frau maureen
auch diese in den diesen weltweit
ablehnende haltung gegenüber trump
entscheidung hat damit zu tun dass man
weiß wir haben doch keine alternativen
zu zwei staaten lösung wir mussten aber
irgendwie daran festhalten
also ein bisschen aus der
hoffnungslosigkeit und deshalb diese
hypothetische festhalten
ich glaube schon dass wir nicht in
palästina konflikt ohne wirklich eine
gesamtstrategie für die gesamte region
lösen können ich glaube dass wir das das
übrigens ich rechne nicht mit einer
zweiten intifada oder anderen neuen das
ist alles plakatives rhetorik die mit
der realität nichts zu tun hat die
weiterhin sind zu erschöpfen zu müde
sie haben keinerlei kraft um wirklich
militanten beleuchtet auch die junge
generation die junge generation ihre
moderation ist sehr gut in meine spricht
von zwei besatzungen sowie ganz genau
was es so sehen sie sind auch mit in das
gehört zur wahrheit sagt ich bin ein
kritischer mensch der seine kritik nach
allen seiten rechnet auch die überlassen
nicht in behörden und eliten haben e
buch hat versagt haben es nicht
geschafft sehr viel die ganzen bilder in
infrastrukturprojekte in bildung
gesundheit wenn ich bedenke dass herr
abbas dann habe ich ja gelobt vorher
auch die was 30 prozent seines etat für
den polizeiapparat das heißt für die
sicherheit zusammenarbeit mit israels dh
die baywa das sind hier behörde
übernimmt eigentlich die drecksarbeit
für die offizielle besatzung und deshalb
das stimmt gar nicht wenn man sage die
ballas sind so nein ich die hamas sie
haben fotos ist ein problematischer
akteur den ich ablehne seien bei seite
aber sie haben einen partner wie muss
ich schauen wir brauchen neue ideen
wir brauchen natürlich für so eine
ehrliche makler position und da braucht
die eu natürlich die zustimmung
arabischer staaten die stimmungs israel
aber auch die usa
das wird nichts daraus gar nichts
bleiben wir noch mal bei der chance
herbeck was würden sie sich wünschen
erst zum schluss dieser sendungen denken
sie glauben sie noch an die
zweistaatenlösung glauben sie ich bin
gespannt was die zukunft uns bringt wir
leben tatsächlich historische momente
überall in der welt sogar hier in europa
katalonien korsika es passieren sachen
auf die welt wenn wir weiter denken wie
wir gedacht haben werden wir nicht vorne
kommen und leider ist es oft so dass in
europa bestimmte kassandra stimmen genau
das wiederholen was uns nirgendwo
gebracht hat und ich glaube dass es wäre
tatsächlich zeigt neue ideen
zu erzeugen aber das heißt also sie
sagen auch oder wie schlecht ich dann
richtig dass sie sagen die zwei staaten
lösung kann es eigentlich mehr sein wenn
es im nahen osten keine mehr arabische
staaten gibt wovon reden wäre und
apropos es gibt schon zu erstatten
gaza ist nicht mehr unter kontrolle von
israel dass seine sonderfall das nicht
überlebensfähig ich habe vorher da wo
angebot also die offizielle position die
arabischen staaten als lager paris die
sache eigentlich aufgegeben
also offiziell das ist eine
scheindebatte und davor zurück und zwei
folgten die araber gegen die zeit
es gibt nicht die araber die arabischen
staaten haben etwas alle gibt den
saudiaraber legen strategischen
beziehungen design das gibt es ja werden
hat anja wird wie ein respektierter
nicht als staatsgast in kairo empfangen
genauso von assisi losbox den ton und
genug also von davon wie muss ich schon
genau hinschauen auf die situation der
paradies auf den lauf die auf eine
region die sich wirklich in auflösung
befindet und dafür den medien konzepte
und überhaupt ein strategisches denken
wie man damit umgeht
okay da das konzert können wir heute ja
auch nicht gefunden aber immerhin haben
wir wieder einen anlass gefunden wie
auch immer über dieses thema zu reden
was auch wichtig ist das war die runde
heute morgen schauen wir die
innenpolitik den morgen treffen sich die
spitzen von union und spd und überlegen
wie eine mögliche gemeinsame regierung
aussehen könnte ich hoffe sie sind dabei
bis dahin tschüss